ja die Impfpflicht die gilt
beispielsweise noch immer bei der
Bundeswehr aber seit heute keine
maskenpflicht keine testpflicht mehr in
Gesundheitseinrichtungen man könnte
sagen okay das war's nein Stopp das sagt
Cornelia stolze es gibt viele Themen
über die wir sprechen müssen und sie
geht sogar noch weiter da muss der ein
oder andere sein Job verlieren sagt sie
ganz klar ihr Thema ja also als ersten
sehe ich da wirklich unsere
Gesundheitsminister Herr Lauterbach der
ja durch sein Verhalten schon zu Beginn
der Pandemie
Ängste geschürt hat massiv der sich
ständig widersprochen hat und trotzdem
sozusagen zu einem Wortführer geworden
ist in den ganzen Geschehen auch obwohl
er eigentlich gar nicht über die
fachlichen Kenntnisse verfügt hat also
er wurde immer dargestellt als
Epidemiologe als Arzt ja er hat Medizin
studiert und das Institut ist er
vermeintlich leitet seit vielen Jahren
wo aber schon seit ewigen Zeiten
eigentlich nicht mehr tätig ist wirklich
wenn er erst der Politiker das trägt den
Namen Epidemiologie auch im Namen aber
er selber ist kein Epidemiologe und als
Arzt hat er eigentlich nie so richtig
gearbeitet und
ich denke letztlich ist er in gewisser
Weise ein ja man muss fast sagen
Hochstapler weil er sich ausgibt als ein
Experte der nicht ist und der auch
vieles sozusagen zu verantworten hat was
die Stimmung ausgemacht hat in diesem
Land der auch massiv sozusagen die
Menschen gedrängt hat sich impfen zu
lassen einmal zweimal dreimal viermal
und auch Zahlen in den Raum geschmissen
hat bei seinen zahlreichen Talkshow
Auftritten die also aus der Luft
gegriffen waren und ähm ich also aus
meiner Sicht ist ist jemand wie er
überhaupt nicht tragbar in diesem in
diesem Amt ähm mir ist auch ein Rätsel
wie eigentlich herr Scholz ihn da in
dieses Amt heben konnte eigentlich oder
den Bock zum Gärtner gemacht wirklich
damit und
ein Teil der Verantwortung dafür tragen
glaube ich wirklich auch die Medien die
in durchgereicht haben er war ständig
ständig präsent und konnte seine
Horrorvisionen präsentieren
das Erstaunliche ist er hat ein
auftretendes
glaube ich viele Leute eigentlich in die
Irre führt weil er vermeintlich besorgt
ist weil er vermeintlich kompetent ist
und weil er sanft daherkommt aber das
macht den aus meiner Sicht auch
besonders gefährlich machen wir es mal
konkret die drei Dinge die Sie Karl
Lauterbach am meisten vorwerfen seine
größten Fehler während der Pandemie also
dass er ganz zu Anfang von wirklich
gigantischen Zahlen gesprochen hat wie
viele Menschen also
jämmerlich sterben werden und er hat
auch sozusagen von von Todesraten
gesprochen die jeglicher Grundlage
entbehrt haben
dann hat er wie gesagt auch für die also
die Impfpflicht wollte erzwingend
eigentlich einführen und hat auch
behauptete Impfungen würden sozusagen
vor Infektionen schützen das wusste man
sehr früh dass sie das nicht tun da die
Studien für die Zulassung auch die
bedingte Zulassung waren gar nicht
darauf angelegt dass wirklich
nachzuweisen diese Studien sind
eigentlich sowieso von Anfang an eine
Katastrophe gewesen das konnte man sehr
bald sehen ja und ähm
man kann eigentlich die Liste wäre ewig
lang eigentlich weil weil er einfach
irrsinnige Forderungen aufgestellt hat
wie diese Pandemie einzudämmen sei er
hat sie aufgebaut ja und er hat
letztlich damit auch finde ich zu
verantworten dass jetzt heute viele
Menschen auch an Impfnebenwirkungen
leiden und dass die auch weggewischt
werden dass sie gar nicht richtig
erfasst werden und es klingt fast so als
würden sie so weit gehen zu sagen er
hatte das Leben nicht geschützt dass die
Gesundheit nicht geschützt sondern eher
gefährdet weil ich bei ihnen aus ja das
würde ich in gewisser Weise so
unterschreiben aber glauben Sie auch
wirklich das wäre ohne Maßnahmen besser
durch die Pandemie gekommen werden also
ich glaube Schweden ist ein ganz gutes
Beispiel dafür dass man ganz anders mit
dieser Situation umgehen konnte
wir sehen ja inzwischen auch das E viele
Maßnahmen gar nicht sinnvoll waren gar
nicht zielführend es waren auch
Maßnahmen die jeglicher Evidenz
eigentlich entbehrt haben das heißt es
ist ja auch nicht so dass man dass die
Menschheit noch nie mit einer Pandemie
zu tun gehabt hätte das ist ja ein
Irrtum also es gab Pandemien die
Influenza zum Beispiel Anfang des 20
Jahrhunderts die die Spanische Grippe ja
wobei sozusagen die auch vor allem ganz
anderen Hintergrund stattgefunden hat
also wo die wo die Bevölkerung
geschwächt war durch Kriege durch Hunger
und so weiter und wo natürlich dann ein
Virus sich viel drastischer auswirkt als
bei einer ja gut versorgten Gesellschaft
wie unsere eigentlich und als
beispielsweise Lockdown
maskenpflicht das sind alles Maßnahmen
die für dies keine Evidenz gab die auch
in früheren Plan spielen die er gemacht
werden von katastrophenschützern das ist
ja auch sinnvoll dass man Pandemien
durchspielt damit man gut vorbereitet
ist auf Pandemien und da haben diese
Maßnahmen eigentlich keine Rolle
gespielt sondern die hat man neu
erfunden und ich erinnere mich sogar
dass zu Beginn der Pandemie hieß es ja
bloß keine Masken tragen auf gar keinen
Fall und dann kam eine wundersame
Wandlung damals war Herr Spanier noch im
Amt eine wunderbarsame Wandlung das
jetzt Pflicht ist also erstmal fingen
viele Privatleute an Stoffmasken selber
zu basteln ich habe das in meinem
Bekanntenkreis auch mitbekommen habe
gedacht was ist mit denen denn los und
dann schwenkte man um zu den
medizinischen Masken die auf einmal alle
tragen mussten und dann kam die ffp2
Maske die auch vollkommen sozusagen aus
der Luft gegriffen ist alt und die
Impfung heute wie sehen die sie es wird
ja trotzdem weiter geimpft sie haben
gerade gesagt der Impfzwang sie ist
genau durchgesetzt werden sollte den
sehen sie äußerst kritisch absolut also
aus meiner Sicht muss das freiwillig
sein das kann überhaupt keine Pflicht
sein sich ein Impfstoff geben zu lassen
wir so wenig geprüft wurde und mit dem
man so wenig Erfahrung hat der absolut
experimentell ist von von der Art des
Impfstoffs mir ist auch ein Rätsel warum
man eigentlich nicht parallel
verschiedene Arten von Impfstoffen auch
klassischer Natur sozusagen ins Rennen
geschickt hat und von Anfang an
praktisch nur auf diese komplett
experimentellen im RNA im Stoffe gesetzt
hat es gab ja noch
die DNA im Stoffe die am Anfang die dann
aber aus dem Rennen ausgeschieden sind
aber man hat überhaupt nicht versucht
andere Wege zu gehen es wurden sogar es
gab ja einen Mediziner in Lübeck der
versucht hat auf klassischen Weg das zu
machen der wurde massiv abgestraft also
diese Impfung hat sich ja erwiesen als
nicht vor Infektionen schützend und das
ist eigentlich die Kernaufgabe eines
Impfstoffs und das konnte man relativ
früh sehen und dann trotzdem an weiter
voranzutreiben eine Impfpflicht
einzuführen also
ich finde man kann das nicht mit
Unwissen oder Irrtum erklären sondern da
muss fast schon böser Wille
dahinterstecken jan ist ja dieser
Abrechnung zu hart nein die ist mir
nicht zu hart weil sie und so schätze
ich Frau stolze ja auf vielen Fakten
beruht ich glaube es gibt dieses
geflügelte Wort in der Wirtschaft das
die Frage untersetzt sich ja auch oder
sitzen wir hier mit einem echten
Experten am Tisch das Wirtschaft viel
von Psychologie abhängt bin ich sicher
ob das stimmt aber wenn man mal davon
ausgeht dass es stimmt dann hängt
natürlich auch die Frage wie gut steht
es eigentlich um das Wohlbefinden einer
Gesellschaft auch extrem von Psychologie
ab sie sind ein Meister des Fach sie
können sich noch viel besser erklären
und da glaube ich liegt ein weiteres
Problem von Karl Lauterbach der in
seinem Ministerium immer noch ein
maskenzwang zum Beispiel hat was für ein
Signal sendet eigentlich Karl Lauterbach
in diese Gesellschaft der sendet
eigentlich dass Signal
dass wir immer noch um gegen sind
umgeben sind von einem uns töten wollen
den Virus das heißt er versucht
permanent in diese Gesellschaft Angst
reinzusenden wir wissen aber auch dass
Angst ein total schlechter Ratgeber ist
gerade in Krisen und wir haben auch
jetzt von anderen Krisen gehört also
eine Gesellschaft sollte eigentlich nie
Angst haben sollte sich Gefahren bewusst
sein aber sollte eigentlich sehr
selbstbewusst sein sich eigener Stärken
besinnen um Probleme die ist immer
wieder gibt auch lösen zu können und
wenn ich jetzt am Samstag und Sonntag
vom Bäcker steht es ist draußen unter
Null im Bäcker sind zwei drei Leute und
vor dem Bäcker ist eine große Schlange
dann muss ich mich fragen was ist hier
eigentlich los und ich habe einfach am
vergangenen Sonntag dann denjenigen vor
mir gesagt trete doch bitte ein ähm
Corona ist vorbei ach so war die Antwort
und dann sind wir reingegangen also es
hat sich so verinnerlicht leider schon
dass und Karl Lauterbach ist jemand der
leider Gottes weiterhin dazu beiträgt
diesen angstmodus den wir nicht nur in
der Schlange vom Bäcker sehen auch an
Schulen weiter zu befeuern
das ist ja das Verrückte die Angst
reduziert das Immunsystem genauso
deutlich wie möglicherweise ein Virus
und es ist sogar noch viel schlimmer
weil dann die psychische und die
körperliche Instabilität zu
zusammenkommt und bei gleichzeitig das
ist jetzt so eine Sache die sich
durchgehen wie ein roter fahren durch
unsere Gesellschaft zieht es passiert
irrationalste Entscheidung wir nehmen
Menschen Hoffnung und Zuversicht und
verlangen von denen sich auf was
einzulassen wo jedes Kind erkennt wenn
jemand geimpft wird und wird trotzdem
dreimal krank dann macht eine Impfung
keinen Sinn das ist einfach so und das
ist Nummer gegeben und dann zu sagen und
dann noch darum darauf zu bestehen dass
etwas wahr ist das denn wenn der
Psychologie sozusagen da versucht jemand
seine eigenen Situation mit Irrsinn und
immer größer Irrsinn zu rechtfertigen
anstelle wirklich einfach mal zuzugehen
ich habe mich verzockt das finde ich
staatsmännisch wenn jemand sagt ich habe
Entscheidung getroffen ich wollte helfen
ich habe mich vertan und nicht versucht
mit meinem Ministerium die Angst
aufrecht zu halten
und das war im März 2020 hier bei mir in
der Sendung und da habe ich Dominika
interviewt sie ist deutsche wohnt in
Paris hat drei kleine Kinder und sollte
dann aus ihrem Haus in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern ausgewiesen
werden sie wurde aus ihrem eigenen Haus
rausgeschmissen und darüber habe ich mit
ihr gesprochen
gestern kann das Ordnungsamt vorbei um
uns zu sagen dass wir das Haus so
verträumen müssen weil
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern nicht unser
erster Wohnsitz ist
wir haben ja auch gesagt dass das Haus
unverzüglich geräumt werden muss was
natürlich völlig unmöglich war mit drei
kleinen Kindern
und
insofern ich konnte sie noch vertrösten
dass wir gesagt haben okay wir räumen
das Haus aber das wird erst heute morgen
stattfinden können und
das haben wir dann auch gemacht also wir
sind heute morgen um 6:30 Uhr haben wir
den Weg nach Frankreich sind wir
angetreten ich bin schließlich deutsche
und meine Kinder sind auch deutsche und
als deutsche Staatsbürgerin vom eigenen
Land ausgewiesen zu werden ist ehrlich
gesagt ganz schreckliche Erfahrung
also das wirklich ein irrsinniges
Beispiel aus dieser Zeit ich muss sagen
das macht mir jetzt noch Gänsehaut wenn
ich dazu sehe was da passiert ist wir
haben mit Dominika gesprochen da war sie
gerade auf einer Raststätte und hatte
die drei Kinder hinten im iPad immer
Auto und hat sich dann die Zeit genommen
mit uns zu sprechen musste das eigene
Haus verlassen Herr Schumann wie so eine
Geschichte hören finden Sie nicht wir
reden jetzt hier über die Aufarbeitung
man müsste sich bei jedem einzelnen man
müsste sich auch bei dominikan
entschuldigen die Politik ich habe sie
erlebt mit der eigentlich nicht
bezogenen Impfpflicht die wir als
Landkreise auch durchsetzen sollten wir
sind ja für viele zuständig und da war
auch ganz klar wenn wir das so
durchgesetzt hätten in der Konsequenz
die Leute hingegangen ich will nicht
sagen dass die Quote schlecht war aber
es gibt natürlich bei dem Ärzte Mangel
den wir haben bei den Krankenschwester
wenn die Pflegeperson überall zahnärzt
und so weiter es gibt Gesetze ich habe
schon gesagt mit den spritpreisbremsen
war dass sie diese einrichtungsbezogene
Impfpflicht auch dahingehend vollkommen
irrelevant weil das gar nicht umsetzbar
war in Gesetz zu beschließen was nicht
umsetzbar ist und ich war zu der Zeit
damals noch nicht Landrat aber
ehrenamtlicher Bürgermeister und die
Situation
muss natürlich sagen zu Anfang der
Pandemie wussten ja alle nicht was was
Phase ist und dass man da Entscheidung
trifft die man hinten revidieren muss
oder hätte man anders gemacht okay aber
überzogene Entscheidung die dann das
betreffen was wir jetzt gerade gesehen
haben kann man ja gar nicht
nachvollziehen also das ist ja habe ich
jetzt auch zum ersten Mal gehört und bin
sehr erstaunt darüber dass man so
stringent durchgegriffen hat ohne dann
wirklich dann Sinn verstanden und ohne
Logik dahinter was das denn für die
Infektionsschutz bedeutet der Menschen
die noch da bleiben also ich unterm
Strich raus könnte man sich durchaus bei
Dominika entschuldigen
würde im Nachhinein ja aber das ihm das
Thema das war ja auch gerade zu Beginn
der Pandemie wo wo viele in Panik
geraten sind ich erinnere mich auch dass
wir ab drei Zettel einlaminiert haben
auf Spielplätzen und jetzt ist der
Spielplatz gesperrt keine Kinder mehr
rauf das hat man erst mal gemacht weil
man dann so natürlich auch durch die
durch die durch die Reaktion des Bundes
auch Stück besser verängstigt war aber
auch die Maßnahmen und die auch schon
Geld sofort geführt wurden wo man schon
glaube ich andere Erkenntnisse hatte was
er Lauterbach jetzt auch gesagt hat dass
sie gewisse Maßnahmen und die Kinder was
gemacht haben jetzt wirklich überzogen
sind ich hoffe wir künftige ähnliche
Krisen in dem Bereich dass man da anders
reagiert Frau stolze zuversichtlich dass
man künftig dass wir das draus gelernt
haben also ich glaube es gibt zwei
Schienen sozusagen das eine ist ich
glaube ich habe den Eindruck dass viele
Deutsche inzwischen aufgewacht sind dass
da einiges schief gelaufen ist und das
dass sie sozusagen auch teilweise in die
Irre geführt wurden viele haben
angefangen zu recherchieren warum hat es
eigentlich konnte das alles eigentlich
stattfinden haben sich viele
umfassender informiert und verstehen
nach und nach auch sozusagen das was
dahinter steckt denn das ich würde sagen
das was gelaufen ist bei Corona war
schief gelaufen ist ist eigentlich eher
ein Symptom als eines tieferliegenden
Problems nämlich einer Verwandlung eines
Filzes der im Hintergrund vorhanden ist
es gibt dann aber sozusagen ein bisschen
die zweite Schiene und das heißt die
Aufarbeitung sozusagen von denen die
sozusagen offiziell stattfinden müsste
und die Verantwortlichen zu Rede stellen
und zu Verantwortung ziehen vielleicht
auch Rücktritte zu fordern
da bin ich mir nicht so sicher denn wer
soll denn diese Aufarbeitung in die Hand
nehmen wer soll denn die Recherchen
machen wer soll denn diejenigen zur Rede
stellen die ja teilweise sich schon sehr
elegant irgendwie verdrückt haben also
Herr Spahn ist für nichts mehr
verantwortlich weil er kommt ja auch gar
nicht mehr an die Akten Herr wiele hat
auch rechtzeitig den Absprung geschafft
und ist jetzt bei wird jetzt bei SAP
unterkommen und andere versuchen
sozusagen zu relativieren wie ein Herr
Drosten oder ein Herr Lauterbach hier an
und da an der an kleinen Stellen so ja
da und da haben wir uns vielleicht
geirrt aber im großen Ganzen haben wir
alles richtig gemacht die eigentliche
Aufgabe der Aufarbeitung könnte bei den
Medien liegen also gerade auch
beispielsweise öffentlich-rechtliche
Rundfunk aber genau da wird es nicht
stattfinden und dann bleiben dran bei
diesem Thema das ist oft Thema hier in
dieser Sendung und das verspreche ich
Ihnen sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
für Sie